i was always on the border of an
anaphylactic reaction which is not
pleasant i couldn't relax at all i don't
like to talk about this much because
it's so bloody radical and i don't like
to propagate it but this diet seems to
have stopped all of that i don't have
psoriasis my gum disease which is
incurable i had multiple surgeries to
deal with it it's completely gone took
three years my right eye which was quite
cloudy it's cleared up completely i lost
50 pounds like instantly and kept it off
i should say for me personally it does
seem that i feel by far the best when i
eat only meat on top of that i
discovered how incredible my mind feels
when fasted when you fast your body
logically and obviously if you think
about it what does your body scavenge
first well
damaged tissue i know the literature on
fasting to some degree and it's very
compelling literature if you starve dogs
down i think it's twenty percent below
their optimal body weight they live
thirty percent longer that's a lot it's
like thirty percent yeah yeah thirty
percent